now to go and rest welcome to the last
episode of outlast I guess it's over
here huh belly
huh Billy huh we're best friends Billy
I'm just gonna [ __ ] kill you with
this soda machine bad idea well what do
you got the camera Oh what am I gonna do
with a camera jeez
how about it bench I don't know how to
kill people come on lover not a fighter
oh jeez
[Music]
now
it's you Billy [ __ ] off Billy [ __ ] off
[ __ ] gum Billy
no bad Billy bad Billy Oh Billy take it
in Billy what that [ __ ] you're not Billy
Goat the quad at either
all right not prowlin it's it's the
ghost that's the ghost and sister ghost
it's just the bellows assist to go it's
just to go just to go if that's the go
it's good to go I'm just gonna turn up
your life support thank you don't touch
me
oh here it is here it is here it is way
of course really gonna dang building
Anna back I'm too fat shut up okay okay
we'll be running with shut up Billy why
did you save me from the fat guy you
secretly loved me you can't come with me
I press we can do this we can do this we
can't do it for pocket Oh
open open open open girl pissed he's not
welcoming in that town Nana Nana Nana
Nana
and then and then in it open place thank
you
shut it off shut it off shut the [ __ ]
thing off look at this epic thing Billy
you're not allowed in here [ __ ] you [ __ ]
Billy [ __ ] Billy look Billy I don't know
even if he's Billy return off the valve
from this I didn't know where the valve
is oh dude what the [ __ ] man you're
looking good girl I love you baby
life-support fluid reservoir he's gonna
die he's gonna done Billy back where is
he where is he
[Music]
wait now come from here
[Music]
so Oh this pink pen is that of a pinky
idiot all right thank you yes of course
yes of course
night-night sweet prince
what
[Music]
no no no no no no never supposed to be
finished yellow fine as long as Billy's
not coming I'm calling him belly for now
I don't even what jump [ __ ] yeah skills
on the hills I can't see okay I'm sure
it's fine I'm sure this is perfectly
fine electric sub general reliable
everything how do I know if he's behind
me hi - oh hey rude is it over here
no I don't know why didn't we do this
before bounds
why I'll squeeze blue Swiss blue baby oh
he's right there oh he's right there
close the door close it Oh God help this
shit's intense
this shit's [ __ ] intent a ladder what
are you doing he dan dan dan dan dan dan
white weather doesn't even bet come on
there's our there oh [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] me
ah we'd be running we meet which way
which way which way which way [ __ ] oh
[Music]
happy place happy place happy place
happy place happy place
up okay weather is this what
but might be done [ __ ] Billy Billy give
up it's over Billy boo he's over Billy
boo I swear to God I will put on you
bill libel if you suck on my shoes I
guess I got this [ __ ] place is so
creepy
Billy why is so mean
Oh what the hell is he doing that
[ __ ] hat I'll be going now but it's
been get talking to you
oh he's after me that's good I was
hoping he would chase me squeeze no that
[ __ ]
shortcut [ __ ] where is his life support
from a [ __ ] No
confidential not anymore
what I clicked on the wrong day hey I'm
gonna film this [ __ ] no no no no Billy
why Billy I just wanted to make youtube
videos oh please how are you to work let
me know and you seem like a fun take it
out Billy why why are you doing this oh
this guy is a [ __ ] tank
uh better it's Oliver thank God my god
[Music]
must make youtube videos yes I [ __ ] but
first must confidential not anymore not
anymore must upload must upload cry
don't care what it takes
this shit's going on YouTube I didn't
come through honest just to fail in yen
gotta make it though I mean a fat guy
gave me nuts timid braced and that
[ __ ] belly that internet must know
about it it's my duty I don't care how
much damage I took I won't make it out
of here
people are gonna [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
I bet this video will have like a
hundred thousand million likes and a
half I bet I will get so many
subscribers
and then everyone knows the more
subscribers Wow
shut that house less fight on the where
was I
the more this could happen [ __ ] why
don't let me finish my sentence body the
my subscribers their more their [ __ ]
the Nazis thus it's been I not good
[Applause]
[Music]
those [ __ ] marathons I knew her
that's fun there's a lot of fun okay
bros it's time for some thoughts that I
have on this game that I think it'd be
fun to reflect upon this was a really
fun horror game all the way through
sometimes horror games can have the
tendency of getting to dragged outs at
some points and and or even getting
annoying
but for me this was just something that
I really enjoyed playing it was always
interesting and it was always fun and it
felt perfect in length and it felt like
a satisfying experience that's what she
said
so for that I am very very happy there
have it's been forever since a great
horror game like this one came out like
like I would compare this one to amnesia
the Dark Descent even though they do
horror in very different ways I still
really like this one it has many many
many many jump scares and I know some
people have a lot of problem with that
but for me they were done really well
like they were so unexpected and so
effective that I didn't but I liked that
I really liked it and it made it it
never made for a never dull moment while
playing this like I said and I'm really
happy for that there has been some
horror games coming out that has been
kind of disappointing and not saying any
names so I'm like thank God for this
game coming out honestly I'm I think
this was a really really fun experience
and I think you bros enjoyed it as well
I also think it would be great to make a
scary montage just for this games I
think I'm gonna do that they were like
or tell me and in the comment section if
you think that's was something you'd
like other than that I want to just say
thank you boys for watching this series
thanks to outlast and the guys over at
red bell gothic guys and gals over at
red bells for giving me this some sneak
peeks early and
and being acted with the community and
and and that kind of things I think they
seemed really cool I wish them all the
best in the future I hope they will make
many many more horror games because I I
can't wait to see what I was are gonna
make other than that stay awesome rest
I'll see you in whatever next series
we're gonna do next
[Music]